ciao mariners bentornati ecco poi un
nuovissimo video ho deciso di farlo
perché mi avete scritto in tantissime su
instagram soprattutto le ragazze
ovviamente perché è un video un po più
da ragazzo e perché siete anzi a sé ten
ansia perché c'è una domanda che vi
attanaglia che ha la stessa valenza di
ansia della domanda cosa fai a capodanno
e questa domanda è sul nuovo gioco di
scolo allora siete tutte in ansia
soprattutto chi magari deve andare prima
dicevo in prima media quindi in una
scuola nuova da non conosce nessuno sì è
vero può che cavolate l'audio del primo
la scuola è importante bisogna pensarci
sono quelli di voi che ci pensano da
giugno e può forse un tantino esagerato
ma sono qui per voi per aiutarvi per
stargli vicino per sostenervi
in questa scelta dell'outfit del primo
giorno di scuola
partiamo subito come primo affi optato
per un bel jeans contattino semplice
bianco abbinato io l'ho scelto bianco
potentemente ammanchi nero di qualsiasi
altro colore pastello che si era
comunque semplice fresco e di chi ha
un'aria pulita e questo è uno degli atti
più belli che ho ed è anche un ottimo
gli che io vi consiglio di più
soprattutto per le serate che sono belle
comode e stupire austro agio potete
anche correre potete ballare
fare qualsiasi cosa e scusate fare un
servizio che un piccolo ma purtroppo in
casa non ne avevo altri con cui fingere
di essere ancora uno studentessa quindi
perdonatemi come sapete
l'epopea dello studio e marina
studentessa sono ormai moventi molto
lontani cct seconda siti che
ripropongono ha mostrato alla marinara
diciamo perché questa mattina a righe
bianche e blu e un motore mood
marinaretta lo trovo molto classico
molto elegante ma comunque sempre casual
c'è una via di mezzo e giusto quindi per
il primo giorno di scuola che si vuole
essere carine ma non troppo tirate un
altro out che trovo molto carino e
l'afrique salopette e l'ho chiamato così
perché appunto è una salopette perché ho
scelto questa saperne o mille
nell'armadio
sono tutte con gli shorts quindi molto
corte va bene per andare in spiaggia al
mare ma comunque non per la scuola
scordatevele sono troppo esagerate e
i soci nella scuola quindi ho scelto
questo test ho preso qualche esempio fa
non l'ho messa molto per primo ho
trovato occasione perché comunque se
devo scegliere llobet ovviamente
l'estate fresco quella quelli short
questa qui però è perfetta secondo me
per andare a scuola perché è comoda non
è fortissima la minigonna e proponi al
limite tra puoi abbinare con qualsiasi
magliettina un prodotto di fantasia in
carica quella volete era troppo molto
carina un po diversa dai suoi outfit
ed ecco winehouse fit che ho dedicato
agli amanti di total black
io sono una mancia è stata all black
inverno sono praticamente sempre total
black per questo motivo magari a
settembre comunque questo credo qui
cercare di evitarlo perché per mesi e
mesi
messi non solo di nero quindi io
sinceramente no 3 per i total black però
tanti muoverò scritto che hanno
intenzione di vestirsi tutti ero una
buona azione secondo me chiude il jeans
nero va l'italia è una gonna longuette
quindi più o meno sotto il ginocchio con
una magliettina magari infilata dentro è
né sarà forse così che è appunto questo
questo giochino che questo effetto
piquet è molto carino star per il
puntino a mettere questo volete a
minacciare anche magari uno stivaletto
un pochino più autunnale ed eccoci
arrivati ad outfit più tamarro allora si
alzi a parte e io trovo molto stiloso si
è abbastanza sportivo abbastanza
un po bar se non vogliamo definire così
però mi piace molto il pantalone l'ho
rubato a salvo e sono i suoi
pantaloncini quando nella basket ematico
il terminale qualsiasi tutto una larga
eccetera eccetera vi mettete una bella
magliettina le scarpe ovviamente io non
riuscirei con le stampe diverse ma per
farvi nelle riduzioni quindi magari
dalla scarpa alta bianca il lo spread
rid oppure una bella della jordan
non ora di valentina vignali sicuramente
lei come se volesse metterebbe così non
c'è una verità perché non penso che sia
più in età scolastica e l'occhiale
ovviamente dettaglio in timore se
immagino per primo da una scuola si
possa anche evitare nel senso va
benissimo anche così però io se uscissi
con questo atleta g al di là del primo
errore il cuore minimi aggiungerei anche
il mio occhiale che i miei preferiti
un giorno che raccontano la storia di
paul chiare signori e signore che
annuncio le entrate dell'ultimo out with
che vi propongo in questo video in
pigiama
ovviamente lo scherzo ragazzi tanti voi
e alla mia domanda cosa mettete primo
giorno di scuola mi hanno risposto e
diciamo che a niente perché non avete
nessuna voglia di tornare a scuola
perché sapete che dal primo giorno di
scuola vi dovete mettere sotto studiare
subire lezioni quindi immagino che non
abbiate tutta questa voglia però dagli
scherzi a parte
mettetecela tutta e quest anno zero
debiti e studiate di volta in volta
anche lo dicevo sempre lo facciamo mai
ma almeno di teheran provarci e e niente
un pigiama lo lasciamo a casa come
torniamo a casa
ed eccoci sfortunatamente giunti alla
fine del video fossero chicca piaciute
vi sia soprattutto servito a provare la
fit perlopiù maggiori scuola o magari a
darvi qualche idea
state tranquilli tranquilli andato tutto
bene
sarà un primo giorno di scuola
fantastico io ovviamente sono qui ad
aspettare vostri messaggi in cui vi
racconterò com'è andata ecco ci tengo
molto e da questo video deciso di
salutare 3 di voi in ogni volta che però
un video su youtube
tutto quello che dovete fare è
semplicemente seguirmi su instagram
iscrivervi un bel direct con il vostro
nome e saluta mille prossimo video mi
chiamo estrarrò tra virgolette
selezionerò 3 di voi e ad ogni video
risolverò mi raccomando se vi è piaciuto
il video se non avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al canale mettete un bel mi
piace e lasciato in un commento
e soprattutto seguite visto tutti gli
altri social instagram musicali e
facebook ad ora